you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
tributes from environmental groups and
conservationists around the world
for prince philip who's died at the age
of 99.
the very real impact of climate change
on people's lives we report from
guatemala where
food insecurity and extreme weather are
forcing thousands from their homes
and more calls for the world's biggest
climate summit to be delayed
again because of the kovit 19 pandemic
greta thundberg says cop 26
shouldn't go ahead unless vaccination
programs mean all countries can attend
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and today we start with the
news that the duke of edinburgh has
passed away at the age of 99.
throughout his life he was committed to
the conservation of nature
and the natural environment in 1961
prince philip co-founded the world
wildlife fund
now the world's largest conservation
organization
he was an early advocate for the
environment a cause he did much to
further
during his lifetime well our royal
correspondent rihanna mills joins me now
so prince philip rhiannon said to be
ahead of his time when it came to the
environment
that's right and i think with his death
of course we are remembering the
hundreds of different patronages and the
charities that he supported
and a large amount of that work
certainly a couple of decades ago was
around the environment as you said he
had those links with the world wildlife
fund
and he was dedicated to those issues of
conservation
and the environment of course in more
recent years we have
become so used to prince charles and
also more recently prince william
talking about those important
environmental issues and specifically
the damage that climate change is doing
to the planet
but i think for the younger royals
certainly that
first few steps that prince philip took
a few decades ago
was really an inspiration to them and i
spoke to prince william
last year when he launched his own earth
shot prize and he talked very movingly
about how prince philip was very much
ahead of his time how he would talk
about issues around
population growth and the damage that
that was doing and
the impact that that was having on the
planet prince philip also had these
ideas about the links between nature
and religion and was very keen to gather
religious groups
with conservationists to talk about
those issues and so as we reflect on the
impact that he's had
i think his environmental legacy will be
hugely important
as we look ahead over the next few days
and remember that remarkable legacy
rhiannon thank you and there's
continuing coverage of this story on our
website
app and social media channels
let's take a look now at the day's other
climate news and we're focusing on
central america where the effects of
climate change are forcing many to flee
north to the united states more than 200
000 guatemalan migrants were apprehended
by u.s border patrol
in 2019. people coming to the u.s
from the northern triangle that's
guatemala honduras and el salvador
now outnumber those from mexico in part
that's because of
this a region known as the dry corridor
where extreme droughts mean that one in
six
people experience food insecurity
skies chief correspondent stuart ramsey
reports from guatemala
he's tiny and he's starving but his
mother's milk simply doesn't have the
nutrition needed to feed him properly
jason gossel is two months old and
weighs just
five and a half pounds
[Music]
he should be double the size at least
next to him his two and a half year old
brother sleeps he's tiny as well
in this part of guatemala everyone is
hungry
just like the brothers there's a food
crisis here
that has gone on for years and it's
getting worse
volunteer aid workers a handful of them
like sofia latona
are all that stopping families like
jason's from starving to death
the reality is that his body is so frail
because of malnutrition
and everything that happens to him will
be a consequence of him being too weak
to fight back
the tell-tale signs of malnutrition are
[Music]
everywhere
with bloated stomachs get almost no help
there's very little their families can
do for them
little food and parasite infested water
is a deadly mix guatemala
now has one of the worst malnutrition
rates in the world
this quiet crisis is being caused by
climate change
the weather is now so variable growing
enough food
has become all but impossible
this is called the dry corridor it
stretches through the central american
countries of el salvador
honduras nicaragua and here in eastern
guatemala
the mountains and the valleys of the dry
corridor appear magnificent and green
but there's little in the way of crops
growing here
landslips caused by flooding are common
recent hurricanes have made it worse
many farmers have simply given up and
left
many joining so-called caravans heading
to the united states
environmental migrants not criminals
leaving homelands
that simply can't support them
well they have pretty meager crop yields
here as a rule
even in the best of times but now a
combination of
no rain intense heat
and a hurricane means that 100
of the local crop has been destroyed
they will get nothing this year
what they're saying is that the weather
is changing all the time
there's absolutely no guarantee when the
rains will come when the right sun will
be there
and then of course they're getting these
wild weather in the shape of a hurricane
and that is making life here really
really difficult
farmers like eduardo rocket try to hold
on
but he showed me his failing crop he's
fighting a losing battle
against the elements
these mountain communities are all
desperately poor all lacking in proper
food and water
but they share another trait there are
virtually no men
they've left to find work to feed their
families
and many never return
many of these children are likely to
find themselves environmental migrants
as well
born into an environment that can't
sustain them
mr ramsey sky news guatemala
in other climate news today the road to
cop is looking more uncertain after
greta tunberg said she won't be going to
glasgow for the summit in november
the environmental campaigner tweeted to
say the climate conference should be
postponed until
all countries can attend on the same
terms she believes any restrictions on
non-vaccinated people traveling
is undemocratic snow leopards lemurs and
peruvian pelicans could face extinction
if global warming trends continue
according to a new study published in
biological conservation
animals from some of the world's most
bio-diverse regions will
disappear if the planet heats up by more
than three degrees
but scientists say it's not too late to
turn it around
and children in england are being
encouraged to make their journeys more
eco-friendly the
government is investing 18 million
pounds on a cycling training scheme
to give young people the confidence to
ride a bike it'll focus on things like
how to tackle difficult junctions
and roundabouts so let's take you over
now to our data dashboard to take a look
at the real-time
power mix in great britain today that's
the figures up here and this shows how
much of our energy is coming from fossil
fuels
from renewables and from nuclear sources
and it shows just what a key role the
weather plays in influencing our
electricity generation
mix now yesterday from midday through to
the evening wind and solar output was
high and that
makes up the bulk of that renewables
figure generating around half of
britain's electricity
today though their output is lower
delivering about 25
of our electricity and that's due to
calmer and cloudier weather
and at the same time colder temperatures
around three degrees below seasonal
average
are driving higher demand for power
leading to a larger proportion of gas
to match supply with demand and you can
see our data dashboard at any time and
read more about what those numbers mean
on our website
that's at skynews.com climate
let's return to our main news now and
tributes have been paid to prince philip
who's died at the age of 99.
he was the first president of the
conservation society wwf uk
and they've tweeted to say we express
our condolences on the passing away
today of hrh
the duke of edinburgh president emeritus
of wwf
international prince philip's lifelong
passion for the environmental cause will
continue to guide us
as we work to protect and restore nature
for people
and the planet and alex sharma the
president of cop 26 summit tweeted
prince philip dedicated a lifetime to
selfless public service providing
wonderful support to her majesty the
queen and was a great champion
for the environment well joining me now
is martin palmer
former secretary general of arc an
environmental organization he founded
with prince philip
thanks very much indeed for talking to
us martin palmer can you describe to us
what prince philip's concerns were about
the environment and climate change
well i know his his concern about the
environment of course goes back a very
long way as you say he was there at the
foundation of wwf in 1961
and poured his energies his passions
into that
and it was out of that really that i
think his particular
approach towards climate change issues
emerged
his anxiety uh very much from the very
beginning when climate change was
beginning to dominate
uh the politics the economic economics
of the
of the environmental world was the
danger of losing sight
that climate change was not the only
issue
uh at one level his concern was that
climate change
i'm saying with biodiversity loss uh and
population issues which as you know was
a big push of his
were all symptoms of a deeper problem
which was that we were out of kilter
with the rest of nature and his
his anxiety about climate change was
that he feared and to some extent he was
right
that it would eclipse focus on oceans on
forests that it would eclipse
focus on the protection of particular
endangered species that it would
not give the same attention to the rest
of
nature as it would give to human needs
and that it will become a major
political
and economic um uh diversion
away from what he felt uh were the major
concerns which was that we needed to get
into a balanced relationship with nature
and so he was very concerned and
we had many many long conversations uh
about this
um he he was very anxious that it was
very anthropocentric
its focus was almost entirely what is
its impact going to be on human beings
um and so for example um when
last year last september september the
un held its first ever
uh summit on biodiversity he was
delighted because he felt
that along with the focus on climate
change and obviously the cop here
in in glasgow in november uh he felt
that
a balance was being restored he was very
concerned
that by focusing only and primarily only
on the impact on human beings
of climate change um we were in danger
of once again
assuming that the whole purpose of
nature was to support human life
and his view was no that is not the
whole purpose of nature
and we've seen of course prince charles
and prince william expressing their
concerns about the environment to what
extent do you think
he was an inspiration to his family on
the subject
i think a very great deal he was an
inspiration
um and i suppose to a certain extent
they also had to sort of find
uh particular niches for themselves
given how much he
was such a very major dominant figure
particularly in the 60s 70s
80s through to the 90s but there's no
question that the passion
particularly i think you see this in the
tusk trust
the their absolute passion to protect
the elephants to protect the most
endangered species
as well as to address other issues that
springs very much from him
martin palmer thank you pleasure
and that's it for today's show but you
can get your climate fix over the
weekend with our podcast
and on this week's episode find out why
dr freddie otto from the university of
oxford
thinks climate change won't be solved if
people feel guilty about flying
climate cast is available wherever you
normally get your podcast from
and of course you can watch our weekly
digital show with ashna harinag on sky
news social channels our app and our
website
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next week